à violer ou les autres titres de
l'actualité le mouvement de grève à la
sncf s'est poursuivie aujourd'hui dans
toute la france et la table ronde entre
les syndicats et le président de la sncf
qui présentait son contrat de plan avec
l'état n'a rien donné jean yves perrin
jean louis quelqu un président très
attendu par les organisations syndicales
devant l'ampleur de la grève tous
direction comme syndicats voulaient se
rencontrer le plus vite possible
au menu de cette table ronde la
présentation de l'avant projet du
contrat de plan mais si les efforts de
productivité à faire par les cheminots
sont listés il manque un chapitre
essentiel
l'argent que va donner l'étape en
contrepartie des efforts demandés et ce
chiffre ne sera connue que mardi
prochain une table ronde qui a pas servi
à grand chose puisqu'il s'avère que le
président bergougnoux hors jeu dans le
dans la protection sociale souris sur la
protection sociale semble aussi hors jeu
sur le contrat de plan qui n'a pas été
capable de nous fournir la moindre
indication sur la position de l'état par
rapport à l'avenir de l'entreprise aux
deux questions posées quant à l'avenir
du régime de retraite et de prévoyance
des cheminots il n'y a pas d'assurance
et quant au contrat de plan on nous dit
on signera comme prévu dans les délais
prévus
c'est justement ce que ne veulent pas
les cheminots au contraire on a plutôt
l'impression que cette réunion ne peut
faire qu'ajouter au mécontentement
ambiant
résultat tous les syndicats de cheminots
appellent ce soir à la poursuite du
mouvement
une grève déjà très suivies ce week end
à paris comme en province à la gare
saint lazare par exemple trois trains
seulement ce soir pour la normandie le
réseau banlieue tourne lui aussi au
ralenti
un train toutes les heures en moyenne
pour chaque destination
en fait tout le réseau ferré français
est touché dans ces proportions
demain la situation sera semblable il
faudra savoir prendre son mal en
patience